Speaker 1: Let's go next to Jack from Connecticut.
Jack from Connecticut, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Good morning, David, Can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 2: Wonderful. It's nice to be back.
I like to bring up a personal topic today.
Speaker 1: Okay. Personal to you or to me?
Speaker 2: Personal to me. Oh, it kind of. Kind
of relates to everyone in this audience. Sort of.
Sure. So about a couple of weeks ago, President
Biden announced that the federal government will
be ending the COVID emergency on the federal scale
and that it's personal to me for two reasons.
Yes. Number one, it's unmanageable. The day is
May 11th, which is also my birthday. Okay. And
number and number two, it's also the day before
the three year anniversary of my grandmother
passing from this deadly and very real disease.
Okay. So I just wanted to ask you a question
about this. Sure. Do you think this is a real
light at the end of the tunnel in terms
of the end of the COVID emergency? Or do
you see this as Biden's way of easing into the
GOP's demands given the high stakes negotiations
regarding budget and the deficit ceiling?
Speaker 1: Listen. So there's there's
sort of two parts to this. The first part is
does Biden ending the COVID emergency change
anything about the reality of what's happening
with COVID out in the world? The answer is,
of course not. It's a political determination.
It's a political change. We have an we have an
emergency. We don't have. If I if right now, if I
was president and I declared Ebola an emergency,
it wouldn't change anything about Ebola.
It would just be a political designation.
So the first thing is this isn't really meaningful
in terms of COVID. Now, in terms of do I think
that the COVID is over? No, COVID is not over.
When you look at global cases and deaths,
they are down quite a bit and they continue to
decline. And there's the question of whether we
say, is this now part of the background level
of risk, sort of like you could go out and
get the flu and you're aware of it, you could
go out and get COVID and you're aware of it,
but we now say we are not considering COVID
something special. We're saying COVID still there,
but we're sort of including it in the total risk
of going out. And you might get a stomach bug or
the flu or get hit by a car, whatever the case
may be. I don't know when the right time is.
I don't think that what Biden is doing is really
being pushed or that he's being kind of pressured
by Republicans necessarily. I mean, very few
people are talking about the federal emergency
designation anyway, and most people aren't acting
like anything is going on anyway. So I think that
it's really more of a political decision and
maybe even a financial decision. But I think
really to figure out what's going on, you
need to be looking at data that is totally
separate from anything Joe Biden says.
Speaker 2: Yeah, It's very unfortunate
that this whole fiasco has turned into a political
situation, especially coming from someone who lost
a beloved family member from this terrible
disease. But fortunately, not fortunately,
as at the time, there wasn't adequate testing
available, so there was no way to point out
anything in a sense. But it's very fortunate to
know that things have improved in some way, and
there's some way we can see some light at
the end of the tunnel, if that makes sense.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, no question about it. And a
lot of the light at the end of the tunnel depends
on personal risk tolerance and a lot of things
that are different for everybody. So I appreciate
the call, Jack, and be well. Okay.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much,
David. I appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. There is
Jack from Connecticut, bringing up a number
of important issues. Let's go next to oh,
I don't know. How about, say, in New
York. Jose, welcome to the program.
Speaker 3: Hello, David. It's by the way,
it's Judy. It's Portuguese, But I'm very
impressed you got the last name, correct?
Speaker 1: I didn't even say the last name.
Speaker 3: No, I'm sorry. Last time when I was
twittering. But anyway. Okay, so my question to
you is. When we look back in like the 1800s and
during the turn of the labor unions. Yeah. And
such like that when people started revolting
and getting violent because their situations
were poor. Yes. Do you think that's something
that may be happening in the future, as if like
the during day six people were clearly angry,
but their anger was directed towards something
else? Do you think we are due for violence?
Speaker 1: I'm not sure I understand what
you're saying. You're saying is it possible
that in the future violence will happen
like on June six, but directed at something
different? I apologize if I'm not understanding.
Speaker 3: Like the government,
like the left side, The right side,
because people situations are so it's so
like diminish from like back in my parents
were we're like starting up and stuff.
Speaker 1: What's what's diminished?
Speaker 3: Like the wages, the cost of
living opportunity for, like, housing. But.
Speaker 1: Okay, so I am just not understanding
what you mean. So getting So you're saying
housing cost is up, wages are flat, so people are
upset. Will that lead to violence, you're saying?
Speaker 3: In a sense, yes. Like if I'm
sorry, I was asked to formulate this question.
When. When people like. I'm sorry.
You can skip over me. I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: All right. I appreciate the call. It
sounds like there's an interesting question in
there. Let's call back. Call back when we figured
out what it is, and I would love to answer it.